so you've decided to start a
youtube channel this year and maybe
you've been watching a ton of different
youtubers and wanting to create content
just like them
but i'm here to tell you that the
content they're creating
may not be what you need to start with
so in this video i'm gonna be sharing
with you the one
strategy that can take you from zero to
ten thousand subscribers
and beyond but if we're just meeting my
name is heather torres and i'm part of
the think team
and we are a team of creators helping
you build your influence with online
video we are on a mission to help 10 000
purpose-driven content creators build a
full-time living doing what they love
with the power of
video and we have been making waves here
on youtube helping creators not only
start from scratch but go
all the way to 100 000 subscribers and
beyond and
you might be here right now with zero
subscribers so welcome maybe you're
under that 10 000 mark
and i'm gonna share with you a strategy
today that i really
feel can be a simple strategy that's
gonna help you get more youtube
videos done in less time because you're
going to know exactly
what to create so let me know if you are
watching
live or on the replay you're watching
the think marketing
live show with heather torres and we're
going to have q a coming up in just a
bit but
if you're ready to get into this go
ahead and smash the like button and if
you haven't hit subscribe yet make sure
you hit that subscribe button
but my question to you is how do you
crack the youtube code
you know you think about youtube you
think about you know how do i get my
videos seen how do i
become someone who people want to follow
right that's why we're here on the
platform we're here on the platform
to create valuable content that can help
people solve
a problem and that's really when you're
starting at zero
the first question i want you to answer
who do i help and how do i help them
what problem do i
solve this is something you want to make
sure you're journaling down
that you've got that in your mind before
you even get
started really on making videos now i'm
someone who started on the platform here
by
you by doing this one strategy i'm going
to teach you with my homeschooling
channel
not only do i uh teach here at think
media but i also
have a side hustle just like you maybe
uh where i teach people how to
homeschool and this one strategy
is what has helped me get almost um
let's see i'm sorry let me go back this
one strategy has helped
my channel grow on autopilot like i am
getting views every single day because
of this one strategy getting discovered
getting found and this is something you
can apply right to your channel
as well now how do you crack the youtube
code
how do you get discovered how do you
allow your views like people to actually
view your videos and really it comes
down to
you answering a question you
answering a question type that in the
chat right now i
need to answer questions and how do you
do that
well we have a formula here at think
that we call
a s q you want to answer
specific questions how do you break
through on youtube this year
you need to be answering specific
questions if i were to start a brand new
youtube
youtube channel right now this is the
one strategy i would use to get
discovered to get views get to my first
10 000 subscribers and beyond
so what is answering specific questions
well how do you even
find that like what questions should i
be answering heather
what i need you to do is write down the
questions that people
in your target audience are asking
so what are they going to the youtube
search bar and actually typing in
well let's see what happens when you go
to the youtube search bar and you type
in
how to right how to is a great way to
get started with
answering specific questions because how
to means i have a problem
i need to learn how to do whatever my
problem is i need to figure out the
answer to my problem
let's say i had in organizing like i was
helping moms learn how to organize
their home one of my friends says this
she is has an amazing channel
uh where she is helping people organize
with dollar tree items but let's just
say i type into the chat
how to i'm gonna type into the chat how
to and then i'm gonna write organize
because if i'm someone who is looking to
figure out how to organize
that's what i would type into the chat
and then guess what happens on youtube
well when you type in how to organize
youtube is going to actually auto
predict different
video ideas for you to create so now
you know what pops out and you get to
see all those different things that
people are typing in you kind of get to
choose which one
when you're the user you're going
through and you're choosing which one
well
as the content creator here on youtube
this
is valuable information why
because it's telling you exactly what
people are writing
into the search bar when they have this
problem and here's what they're typing
in
they're not just typing in how to
organize that's still pretty broad
what they're typing in is how to
organize your closet
right if i have the problem where right
now i have three kids
that are in one room and i have a tiny
little closet i need to figure out how
do i organize this closet
i'm not just going to the platform
saying how do i organize my home
i am specific with an exact problem so
you want to answer specific questions
what about this one
how to organize my dresser drawer wow
that's pretty specific i mean when you
think about your whole entire house
right like right now you're probably
sitting in your office or maybe in your
your uh in your living room or maybe
you know you're in your kitchen you're
listening to me while you're cooking
dinner right now
there is a lot of things in your house
that you may need to organize right
well every single one of these search
terms
is a video and people are very specific
with their problems did you see that the
difference there
one was how to organize that's the first
thing that was typed in
but look how specific people get with
their problems
a dresser drawer i mean
that's pretty specific right when you
think about all the things in a home a
dresser
drawer is very specific so you want to
be answering specific
questions what about this one well if
you are someone who's in maybe the
health and wellness space
and you want to help people lose weight
well they're not really typing in
how to lose weight i mean that is a
problem that's kind of the broader
problem
but what's the specific thing they're
trying to accomplish
what do they actually need from you well
here you can see when you type in how to
lose weight the video idea that you
could be creating right now if this is
your niche
how to lose weight in four easy steps
yes i want to know that please tell me
how about
how to lose weight in one day you can
sign me up for that video i will watch
that video if you make that video okay
these are the specific questions that
you could be answering
when you're creating videos now i'm
gonna let you in on a little secret
right now think media our main platform
has over 1 million
subscribers guess what kind of videos
we're making
these videos we're answering specific
questions so if you're just starting and
you're at zero
and you're needing to know what kind of
videos to make
i want to let you know that this
strategy this one strategy
this could help you get to your first 10
000 subscribers
all right well let's try this what about
uh how to lose
weight fast without exercise yes i want
that one as well
all these ones are really great ideas
but what you'll notice here with the
blue arrows
is i by typing in that one key phrase
into the youtube search bar i now have
one two
three four five videos
that i could create and guess what each
one of those videos are doing
they're answering a specific question
well what happens uh here we go your
power question is
uh what is your target audience typing
into
the youtube and google search bar
what are they actually typing into the
youtube and google
search bar a lot of times we think okay
i need to like sit down and plan i need
to like
i need to you know i really need to get
into the psychology you do
you definitely need to but can i give
you a little secret
a lot of this is right in front of you a
lot of this
is you actually just asking the people
you want to help hey
what do you type into the youtube and
google search bar
when i started my homeschooling channel
this was the exact
strategy that i did i went to about four
different girlfriends that i have that i
knew
were in the process of deciding if they
wanted a homeschool and i
said to them hey what are you actually
typing into
the youtube and google search bar and
they said things that i wouldn't have
really thought about
and i thought huh how interesting i was
able to do how to
homeschool on a budget because they had
a budget i wouldn't have thought of that
but that's what they were actually
asking so your power question is
what is your target audience typing into
the
youtube and google search bar remember
answer
specific questions that's the key to
today's training answer specific
questions and i want to share with you
a couple of our students from our
academy that are doing this exact
strategy and getting
amazing results this is tara now tara
is in network marketing she does
essential oils and
she decided that she wanted to break
through on youtube to be able to
discover
more people that would come into her
business and purchase the products
now one of the things in oils is you
have these different types of
diffusers and a lot of times people will
get the oils and they have no clue what
to do with them
and so tara decided to answer the
specific
question ways to diffuse oils without
a diffuser right because it's two
different pieces and so she was
answering that specific question i don't
know if you can see it here but
this video alone has 13 000
views this is tara who just started she
picked up a camera and made a video
about answering specific questions this
is mary
i love mary because mary had never used
a camera before
in her life mary is in her legacy years
and she decided that she wanted to take
the
thing she was teaching to women at her
home into
the digital space so mary picked up a
camera and she started creating
these videos that were answering
specific questions
like this question how to make no need
sandwich bread i didn't even know that
that was a thing
but mary's audience was asking this
specific question
how do i know well oops let me go back
because mary
has a 173 000
views on this video her target audience
was asking this question this is ken
kent roland is a cowboy this is cowboy
kent
he loves cooking and he does a lot of
country style
cooking well you'll notice here kent
decided to just
answer the specific question here's what
he answered
easy tricks to cleaning a cast iron
that was the that was it that's all he
had to ask that's all he had to answer
3.1 million views
are you seeing the power of this
answering specific
questions now this is sheri sherry loves
sewing sherry uh decided that she wanted
to leave her corporate job and be able
to do her hobby full-time and so
she decided to start answering specific
questions
now what i love about this is that she's
just reviewing one
actual sewing machine and if you know
anything about sewing these are not
inexpensive
items this is an investment and so she
decided to go ahead and
answer the question about this machine i
love that sherry has
now been able to leave her corporate job
and do youtube
full time because she decided to answer
specific
questions this is joey he is an eye
doctor if you've been around think media
you've heard us
mention joey a time or two what i love
about what joey does is
he answers specific specific questions
man i'm going to say that like 10 times
fast and it's definitely going to like
trip me up so if you're like me you can
say it with me but
what i love about this is that joey's at
1 million
views on just contact lenses for
beginners
his audience had a question i'm new to
contacts
i need to learn how to do this how do
you like open your eyelid and then like
touch your eye
how do you keep it all like moist and
what what do you do like i'm a beginner
and so he decided to answer that
question one
million views it's not like he's some
famous
vlogger joey is an eye doctor
who decided to pick up a camera and
start answering
questions and then this is nicole nicole
uh decided to
answer the question of tummy time nicole
is an occupational therapist and a
parenting coach
and she decided to go after uh
this keep word phrase here tummy time
now if you don't have a child you're not
searching tummy time
but if you do have a child and you're in
her target audience
you are definitely searching this term
it is a developmental thing that kids
are doing
and it is highly searched on youtube
well she decided to do tummy time for
newborns
and nicole did that video tummy time for
newborns
you could see it here and then guess
what happened she made a video
about that 2.4
million views why she
picked up her camera phone and recorded
and answered
a specific question now here's what i
love so much about nicole i
just recently pulled these stats from
her channel and nicola right now is
generating over 300 000
views on her channel that is incredible
what i love the most
about what happens when you start
answering specific questions
is you start to not just grow in your
views which is really important
but you also start to create a community
on
youtube and that's what nicole is doing
with 5 000
new moms a month actually signing up to
be
a part of her community so what action
do you need to take
what do you need to do next well your
action is to make a list of 10
questions what are people typing into
the search bar how specific can you be
remember when i typed in how to organize
it came up with how to organize my
dresser
drawer so you want to be really specific
on the question that
you are answering and then lastly you
want to create
one smart video per week
so if you're going to be answering those
questions if you're starting at zero
subscribers
if you're trying to grow your youtube
channel right now this year
then you need to be making one smart
video per week now what do i mean by
smart video
i mean put your time and energy into
answering
a specific question and this uh little
training was brought to you by
our new think master class this is a
free youtube class
you actually have happening right now we
recorded it live
last night it's gonna be up for 48 hours
so you do have time to still watch this
free class and what i love about this
new free class is that we're talking
about what is working right now on
youtube
now i'm sure you've probably watched a
lot of videos on youtube
but did you know that youtube is always
changing did you know that there's
always
updates and new things that you need to
know about how to dominate on this
platform well
sean cannell the ceo of think did a
free youtube class you do have to sign
up for it it is not on youtube you have
to go
and watch this class separately and what
i love is that he's sharing the three
secrets to use
to youtube success and the mistakes that
most creators are making right now so
if you've watched that masterclass let
me know in the comments
if you're getting value out of today's
video hit that like button
share this with a friend and i want you
to watch this quick
video uh that will help you know a
little bit more about where to go if you
want to take the class and then
we're going to get into q a here on the
think marketing joe
are you ready to start or grow your
youtube channel
do you feel stuck and need help
connecting the dots join this free web
class where you'll learn the
step-by-step playbook for youtube
success
we've helped thousands of purpose-driven
entrepreneurs
just like you grow their influence with
video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
all right well we are going to jump into
the q a part of today but
i'd love to know what was your aha
moment from today's
training what was your aha moment from
today's training i want to shout a
couple people
who are on today gil i see you our gm
and life
uh welcome you are jamming last night
with us on that master class for
a few hours uh thank you so much for
being here pamela and ricardo
and betsy and mama juice podcast
uh we've got sean cannell is at is think
media right now we also have elena from
the think team
welcome amber thank you so much hey let
me know what your aha moment was
for that training what questions are you
going to actually
start making uh for answering specific
questions we're going to bring some
people on so
alina from the think team has actually
dropped a link where it says
join heather live for q a right now
uh you click that link and you uh you're
gonna need to make sure you've got
google chrome
you're gonna come into the back end with
me and then tony from our team is
curating people to come on so you can
definitely come on
uh and i will answer your specific
question all right so looks like first
off we've got
gadget master gadget master is gonna
come on if you wanna
come on let me get you in here
is host oh we're going to bring gadget
master back on
looks like we had a little trouble with
his video there we're going to bring him
back
on um let's see who is next looks like
we've got
nim on hey how are you doing
good just good uh my name is inman
slimer
and i'm a youtube talk show host part
time on life i do
um some gaming
awesome what question do you have for me
today well since we're going to
see what subscribers my question for
everybody today is um does
how to start a talk show is a good topic
for everyone
meaning should you do a talk show or do
you mean
the actual video should you start a talk
show
like on starting one
yeah i think that is probably something
that people who are interested in
starting talk shows
would be searching and i think one of
the best ways to do that is to actually
leverage
other people's influence when you're
talking about the benefits of starting a
talk show so
i would think about uh looking at like
joe rogan or looking at
um uh um dave ramsey or you know people
who are doing
online video that are doing a talk show
form
and i would leverage them and give maybe
five reasons
why it would be a benefit for a talk
show okay
awesome thanks so much for coming on
tonight
thanks well um
that is uh i'm gonna see if we've got
gadget back we don't have him back so
i'm gonna bring on danny danny you look
like you're
next up let's see or tony who is next
tell me who is next coming up here real
quick
but if you oh there we go jake is
actually next we've got jake coming up
right now
hey jake how you doing i'm good how
about you
good uh tell us who you are uh where
you're watching from
your youtube channel and your question
so
my name is jacob marshall my channel is
the psychology spot
um and i'm from waso wisconsin
and my question is um how do you know
like
when to like send uh videos to your fans
or
people versus like connecting with them
and then just like
um developing a relationship with them
okay so sending them what do you mean by
sending them a video give me an example
like um like for example the rocket
process
of um in the vra so like um spending
time with that
versus like um like not being too spammy
but also like
making sure that they know when your
videos come out and like developing
relationships with them
i love that okay so jake is a video
ranking academy member then right or you
know about our system awesome so thanks
so much
um okay so really good question so
you're saying what we teach
inside a video ranking academy is a
rocket system which means
once a video comes out you want to be
spending time pushing that video to
your audience you can do that through
email through social media
there's a lot of different ways that you
can make sure that that video starts to
get video
virulosity that you're getting views to
that video so jake's question is
when do you know to do that and when do
you know to just you know connect and be
with your audience is that right jake
yeah yeah so uh my oh man
oh man can you hear me there we go oh i
thought i had a little glitch and tony
and i in the back we kind of just
if i go out tony's here so jake your
question is
uh when should you do that i think that
every single video that you have going
out
when you're sharing it on social media
oh tony there you go tony help me out
tony help me out
i am here so sorry i got from the back
end so let me take over heather real
quick because she has to
unplug and plug back in her cam real
quick so you're asking about sharing
your video right to
get more views that you're talking about
in other places
okay so sorry or it's it's like um
like knowing when to spend time
connecting with
uh your fans and the people that watch
your videos versus just like
sending them videos um because like
you know you can only have so much time
to um talk to them and stuff
oh that's that's a great question
actually so here at think media we do
get a lot of comments
and stuff that asks those kind of
questions like like it's too much like
we actually
can't physically keep up with it it's
just it's incredible size
so we do try a couple things we find
that videos are the best answers to
questions
so like just because you're like sending
them a video maybe to like answer that
question or
or whatever that that answer is the best
for them and you can kind of
suit it in the comments back to them
like oh hey like this video talks about
this this and this and even if you want
to send a time code instead of time code
at this point in the video
but we just find that it works best if
you give them more resources
because you can't multiply yourself
really like if you if you leave it all
to you to answer everything and talk and
connect with everybody like
you just can't do it anyways it's not
realistic so you do anything you can
to build in ways to do that um kind of
more automated so like whether that's
you're gonna send videos to people
also i mean you're talking about like
youtube comments yeah is that what
you're mostly talking about or is it
okay
it's more um like just like direct like
one-on-one um connection with a specific
fan okay so a specific one-on-one like a
dm you're talking about
yeah okay yeah um i would obvi honestly
at a smaller size maybe it doesn't hurt
you as much as you can connect with
people one-on-one in dms and do those
kind of things
but just also knowing that that's not
really a scalable thing what i mean by
that is as you get bigger
it's impossible to do that right so in
any way you can do
things where you're not personally
answering back a bunch of people in dms
is great or you can just send them a
link like that i totally think that's
okay
like that's totally fine and i honestly
would lean more towards links if it
really like answers the question like if
they're like
oh how do i you know what what niche are
you in or what kind of channel do you
have
so um you reviewed it earlier on the um
the tony step it was the psychology spot
yep
okay yeah so okay so i see you i see
where your questions coming from too
okay
so with helping people especially
through like personal
like you're like in psychology and
talking about like helping young people
so i think it's really easy jake to be
to be like i want to be the hero
i want to help them and i just want to
remind you
and everyone here that has a youtube
channel
like you're you're not superman and
you're not you're not
it's actually not scalable not possible
for you to be superman for them and what
i mean by that is
you can't be there for them at all hours
of the night you can't be there for
everybody at all times and i wish
i wish we could that'd be amazing
because you just can be there for people
all the time
so what i would do is um especially for
your niche and helping young people and
especially with
make sure you have great resources to
send to people not even just videos
but also other tangible resources to
help them if they're especially they're
reaching out in a time of need
and they're having a time of you know um
really like mental health issues those
kind of things
i would make sure you have great
resources to to refer people to
um because that way they can get ongoing
help so that's what i recommend
yeah for sure okay awesome
any other follow-ups to that are you
good yeah could i ask another question
yeah sure so i was wondering um well
thank you for that tip
that's good um i was also wondering how
to know like
um i know that in growth video live
vanessa lao talked about like
experimenting so i was wondering like
what uh
if if uh somebody should like experiment
or if they should
um or if they should just like start
with a niche specific channel
versus like um yeah this is a great
question and i think hopefully a lot of
people in the chat can
can like identify with us let me know in
the comments here if you guys can
identify with us is that sometimes
you're going
um you know oh it's it's better in my
mind to be more successful in youtube to
start with a niche
but it's not just fit your passion or
your excitement level at that time
um i know i struggled with that
especially early on youtube
i struggled with finding something that
would grow but also maybe passionate
about
so here's what i would say is that at
the beginning in youtube
it's okay to experiment like i would
just experiment experiment that's like
if you're just starting on youtube and
we're in the title this video is if
you're starting from zero
and you don't really have an idea of
what your channel should be about or
maybe you have an idea what your channel
should be about and you're kind of like
i'm not sure if i like this anymore or
you're like i want to change
yeah it's totally okay to experiment and
here's the thing is that
you know our journey of a company of
being think media came from
experimentation it wasn't something that
was started off from day one this is
what think media is going to be
it actually evolved and molded over
years and so what i would encourage you
and everyone watching is
don't get especially early on don't get
too locked in
like don't go don't go my channel is
only this it will only ever be this
because success success can take you
from different angles you don't you
don't you don't even see it coming
sometimes and so
i would encourage you that if you're in
an experimental stage and you're like
hey like i'm still like early in my
channel
dude experiment try stuff like you could
like if you're like oh i want to try
like
maybe doing more like these style of
videos i would totally experiment with
it
now the only cat that i would say to
this is that if you have a channel that
has momentum
and it's like your channel with
psychology and those kind of things
and you decide to pivot and go i want to
make a tech channel now
those are like two completely different
channels
like right those are like two completely
different things like what people
subscribe to your channel for initially
isn't what you're actually giving them
anymore so
i would encourage you to experiment try
to experiment within your channel
promise
as much as you can and then if you're
going to change complete directions
um you might want to look at doing a
different channel just because the
subscriber base wouldn't be
great for your new direction so
hopefully that helps
but we're going to get to the next
person here thanks for coming on man
appreciate it
thank you tony awesome time
tony in the clutch guys this is real
life okay you know what really just
happened
people are saying youtube broke i don't
know maybe youtube did break and i just
experienced the worst thing
to happen at the same time guys my
camera stopped working in the middle of
a live stream you want to know
how embarrassed i am right now like i'm
gonna push through tony i'm gonna push
through but i'm so grateful for you
being in the back
and uh and helping out and jumping on
right now and kudos to you for having
like your room clean
and ready to go with the think hat on i
mean i know i was ready for the brand i
was like i
mean i could have adjusted some lighting
i guess real quick but i was like hey
we're just going
yeah you know at some point you just
gotta push through the hard things i
will remember this day
probably for the rest of my life because
in the middle of a live stream with
probably thousands of people at least
hundreds of people
i literally just stopped streaming so
that is
life tony from the think team uh is um
one of our certified coaches inside of
video ranking academy and jake was part
of our academy so so grateful that you
were here tonight jake
asking those great questions and uh
teamwork makes the dream work that's
right i like this one cedric teamwork is
just what we need yes gil heather
i did break that's let's just say that
heather you just broke youtube tonight
yeah that's what happened
um hey i'm excited we do have a couple
more people uh looks like we've got
athena in the back so tony if i
freeze again you jump in all right i'll
be ready
i'll be ready dreamwork can we give tony
a shout and if you liked what tony just
did
smash that like button because we love
tony ariola all right tony you're out
hey athena how are you hi
hi i'm great how are you i'm doing great
hey tell everyone who you are
where you're watching from an amazing
job
um i'm from san diego and uh my question
i'm sorry to just hop right into it but
i know you have other people
um i've been experimenting with youtube
just very much like tony's been talking
about
and i wonder if i kind of messed up by
shadow banning myself accidentally so i
had a channel with zero subscribers
and i subscribed to myself from my own
um
am i echoing are you hearing me twice
okay it's just me okay
thanks that um yeah so i just wanted to
know if i could have possibly shadow
banned myself by subscribing to my
channel from my own
channels um no okay good so i didn't
mess that up
don't worry so i want to ask why um
what what is the reason for your
thinking because you're not growing or
you're being your youtube videos are
coming down or tell me what's happening
so i actually um
so i had like a certain amount of
subscribers and then i got less
even though i had like subscribed more i
have like 10 channels so i subscribed
from like 10 but i only have four
subscribers so i was like
do they know uh did i shadowband myself
that was kind of
my confusion yeah really great question
nope um i mean
we we have channels subscribed to other
channels
um that's fine youtube views a
subscriber as a subscriber what i would
say
is i want you to commit to creating
consistent content that will grow your
channel because here's the thing about
youtube and
with anything really at some point
we just kind of stopped watching certain
certain people i went through actually
last week
i was subscribed to all these channels
that i wasn't watching anymore and i was
like
why do i even why am i even subscribed
they're showing up on my home page
they're in my feed
i don't really need this anymore and so
just as a normal human
i just unsubscribed and so i want you to
commit to making good
content that's going to attract more
subscribers and know that we're always
going to have
attrition in youtube there's always
going to be videos
that people don't like and it's just
that video that they unsubscribed to you
from so
i would just say commit to the process
now athena you said you have 10
channels i'm gonna just ask you to
narrow that focus down
right instead of putting things out
everywhere really focus on
growing one channel first so hope that
helps you tonight thank you so much for
being a part of the live stream and
we'll see you soon
thank you yeah wow that is uh
that is a really great um you know i
i feel it all the time i run this
channel here we've got think media i've
got my homeschool channel
it sucks to see people not subscribing
to you right i get it i
i take it personally but at some point
you just have to know that
there is really just human you know
humanness
i guess you could say and that we just
kind of unsubscribe to certain things
we're into things at some point we're
not into things
but if you start noticing that you're on
a very decline
of subscribers maybe you've switched
your message too much
maybe you are totally pivoted in a new
direction
so there's a lot of things to take into
account but you really want to make sure
that you're creating
valuable content and remember you don't
want to upload a video
your subscribers didn't ask for so if
you're starting to pivot your channel
and you're not getting the you're
starting to see subscribers leave
that could be a reason why so that's
just one thing
uh for you and looks like we've got a
food for thought coming in next and
to let you know again this is brought to
you by think master class you can go to
thinkmasterclass.com if you
want to learn more about youtube if
you're like heather
yes i'm raising my hand this one tip
that you gave me was amazing but i need
more
i am ready for more i need to binge some
think content
this is the next place for you to go you
want to go to thinkmasterclass.com
and you can register for a free class
that sean cannell has put together
that allows you to not only learn his
key strategies but you're going to learn
the mistakes that most
creators are making right now so go to
thinkmasterclass.com
if you are ready to uh sign up for that
class it's only up for 48 hours
so if you haven't watched it yet you're
gonna want to make sure you go over and
register
for that class all right we've got food
for thought coming on hi eddie how you
doing
hi i'm doing really good heather how are
you doing i'm doing great after my
fail that i just had but life goes on
right we're here
definitely definitely so um eddie tell
us who you are
where you're watching from and what
question you have um
i am in urban homesteader um i'm in the
middle of a town in
ontario canada um the channel is my twin
brother and myself
but he now lives in british columbia and
i live in ontario
so other ends of the country um because
of
him moving away um like three years ago
the channel really
slowed down like we were quite
successful uh we were just under 50 000
subscribers
um that has dropped off some but now
we're back in
how do we bring those subscribers back
into the fold as such
yeah really great question and what a
great niche to be in that is both proven
and profitable so what a cool niche
you said you were in urban uh
homesteading which means that you are in
a
prime niche for where we are right now
so how do you bring those subscribers
back how do you reactivate them right
um you want to deliver the content they
subscribed for so
one thing that i recommend is not doing
um kind of the traditional
youtuber like hey guys so sorry we've
been out you know this happened in my
life and this stuff happened like
they don't they don't need to know that
you're just gonna come back with a
vengeance and you're gonna start pumping
out those videos again
you're gonna re-engage them through the
comments
you're gonna you know try and get them
to um
to go deeper with you what videos do you
want to see us be creating like you want
to get your subscribers involved
in the creation process so i would
recommend going back to at least
one video a week being consistent on the
platform is really important
and creating valuable content that they
subscribed for
is gonna be key i would also maybe even
do things
um where i don't know if you since you
guys are in two different locations
um you could even do certain types of
videos where it's your
farm or it's his farm or maybe it's
you're answering the question he's
answering a question
editing is amazing there's so much you
can do with you know with that ability
but i would just say that you want to
just make sure you're you know what the
value proposition is
what did someone subscribe for and then
i would go
hardcore into making those value-based
videos
and doing the tip that i talked about
today eddie answering specific questions
because
yeah that's what mentioned yes because
the niche that you are in
right now there are hundreds of
thousands of people
trying to figure out exactly what you do
and what can happen eddie is that we
will fall into what's called the curse
of knowledge
to you planting tomatoes is like you
could do that in your sleep probably
right yeah for me who's never planted
tomatoes
i don't know what mixture of nitrogen
soil i need
i don't know how to do it in a raised
bed does it need to be a two inch raised
bed or do i need a six inch or do i need
a five foot like
i don't know what i don't know and so i
want you to really go back to the
beginning
of when you started and where they are
starting from
and answering those specific questions
are going to be
key for you succeeding right now on
youtube
okay thank you so much i'll see you soon
because i just actually signed up today
for the academy
oh my gosh i wish i had a reaction
button but i'm so
excited for you eddie is now a new
member of our signature course video
ranking academy
you're going to crush it eddie i can't
wait you're going to be a success
student already i can tell because
what a cool niche i love what you're
doing uh where can people find you on
youtube eddie
um type in food for thought
then you you'll see a little two
characters that are cartoons that are
two twins
that's us awesome well thank you so much
for being on tonight and i'll see you
inside the academy will do thanks very
much heather take
oh i love that so much guys i want to
learn how to be an urban farmer
so bad um i'm gonna watch i'm gonna
binge watch like after this i'm going to
binge watch
eddie's youtube channel because i want
to learn how to do it so bad and that
did you see i just want to bring you
back this is going to come back to the
whole part of what we're doing tonight
answering specific questions and knowing
exactly what your target audience is
searching for
i i know eddie's doing urban uh
homesteading which means
growing your own food you know really
doing it in a
not on a five you know 500
acre ranch he's doing it in an urban
setting and so
i as a beginner as a novice i'm
searching for that stuff
right now i'm trying to figure out do i
buy organic soil
what is plant food like i don't even
know what that is right so
i want you to remember that you have a
target audience when you are in
a proven and profitable niche there is a
target audience that is
binge watching things on youtube and you
could be the one that comes up
if you have zero subscribers you could
be the one that comes
up where they're watching your videos
that's how you get to the 10 000
subscriber mark by answering
specific questions uh i love this tony
said
where do you sign up for the master
class tony you're going to want to go
here to thinkmasterclass.com
that's where you can find the master
class where we go deeper into
uh more about how to do youtube right
this year and what's changed on youtube
and the three secrets for youtube
success
this is a critical master class if
you've not watched this for youtube
class and you are serious about youtube
this is your next step i want to thank
you so much for
being on tonight and if you uh have not
already make sure you hit that like
button
subscribe to this uh channel
and we will see you on the next video
you can click right here on the screen
and you can check out the next video
thanks so much for watching and we'll
catch you next time
bye